[Music]
foreign
chime in Russia's rostov in celebration
of Orthodox Easter as worshipers flocked
to pray and have their traditional
painted eggs and Easter bread blessed
many had the war in Ukraine on their
minds I
have relatives in
and a lot of them have died it is scary
to talk about it because I might be
persecuted for what I'm saying now it's
very scary
there's a war between good and evil
going on and we understand perfectly
that evil wants to win nobody likes our
Orthodox world everybody wants to
destroy it
in Moscow President Putin attended
Easter Service led by patriarch kiril
soon after Russia launched its invasion
of Ukraine the Russian Orthodox
patriarch announced his Church's support
for the war
the Ukrainian Orthodox church already at
odds with Moscow after the annexation of
Crimea responded by announcing it would
cut all ties to the Moscow patriarchate
theologist Andrei kurayev says the
Russian church still hopes not All Is
Lost
Moscow is fooling itself into thinking
that those people are its followers and
this is false we've already seen Moscow
making a similar mistake we're thought
that once Russian tanks appear on
Ukrainian borders they will be greeted
with flowers by Orthodox ukrainians of
the Moscow patriarchate they did not
in Ukraine soldiers marked the holiday
with food sent from home and donated by
locals
the church in Kiev also encouraged
worshipers to celebrate
this year like the previous year we
celebrate Easter to the sounds of cannon
fire but no sorrow or tragedy can
overshadow the joy of the holiday the
resurrection of Christ is the victory of
divine love over human malice of light
over Darkness
as the fighting continues in Ukraine
many pray for the violence to be over
Dimitri medvedenko Al Jazeera
Poland has suspended food imports from
Ukraine until the